New York Police Department has been hit
very hard by this pandemic more than
5000 NYPD members have tested positive
and at least 38 officers have died John
Miller the Department's Deputy
Commissioner of intelligence and
counterterrorism was one of those
hospitalized with a corona virus Miller
we should let you know as a former
senior correspondent for this very
broadcast so first on CBS this morning
he joins us from NYPD headquarters where
he's back on the job John Miller let me
just say this you are a sight for sore
eyes and I speak for CBS News which I
have no authority to do by the way to
say you are a beloved in the building
and we are so glad you're okay I can't
stress how much I'm so delighted to see
you this morning so everybody has a
different experience with coronavirus
briefly tell us what was yours what
happened because we all heard it got
very serious for you well I was with the
disease it was 10 o'clock you know on a
weeknight she called the doctor home it
said temperature's going up to 103
oxygen levels are going down and you
know I'm worried and he he got me on the
phone and he said I'm calling an
ambulance you could go into the hospital
and I said I am NOT going to hospital in
an ambulance I said I got a police car
outside I can take myself to the
hospital and he said well I'm calling an
ambulance and I said well I'm gonna be
the team now right there so don't bother
so I surrendered to Lenox Hill Hospital
and you know I gotta say I was I I'm not
I did because within a couple of days I
realized without all the oxygen that I
was on 24/7 I wasn't going to be I was
gonna be at the oxygen levels the heart
rate the the ability to breathe and the
team there you know my doctor Stewart or
sure the nurse is there Marisa
Madeline Caitlyn
say on Isaac amazing because remember
they're in crisis the professionalism
was amazing and the kindness to and you
know the second part is optional they
have to be professional but they were
they were incredible there yeah we can't
thank them enough the more stories you
hear the more you hear how they always
go above and beyond the call of duty
we've we've got pictures of you John in
the hospital in clue d'ang one that i
think is a funny shot it looks like you
on a TV screen where they're reporting
about you and you're sitting there in
the hospital bed that had to be a little
disconcerting had just left he said you
know you're doing fine there was a lady
in there taking blood from me and she
looked up at the screen and looked down
and he said yeah that's me and she said
that's you and I said and says I'm in
serious condition
she said you're fine stop it experience
yeah
listen thousands of officers are now
returning to work after being diagnosed
with Co but what's being done to protect
the force well this has been you know
stay ahead of that you know nothing else
works people call the police and that's
the part that has to work so you know
the department has been going 24/7 but
you know when you when you have 5000
people out sick who are going out at a
rate of 300 a day you know thank god
that's down to about 1800 now our normal
sick rate on an average day without a
pandemic is 2.73 percent you know we
were we were approaching much bigger
percentages than we'd ever seen before
so how do you buy a million masks a
million sets of gloves how do you find
them right now yesterday that involved
the Deputy Commissioner for Management
and Budget the city controller the
administrative services for the city but
they got that together if you go to a
police station or police headquarters
now
doesn't matter if you're police officer
the commanding officer the Deputy
Commissioner or a prisoner in handcuffs
you're being scanned for your
temperature before you go in if the
temperature is high or you answer the
questions about context you've had you
know that goes into a higher level of
screening it's about the social distance
distancing the protective equipment and
making sure that you you catch these
things every way you can so you get
people help we've all gotten the orders
now we just have to follow them but John
we have to talk about a story on the
NYPD's making national news and not in a
good way I know you've seen it the
optics are not good
a man was arrested in connect all right
I've been your John what can you tell
we're gonna we all right now oh he's
frozen you're having trouble with Gale
shot okay John go ahead John so yeah a
couple of things one anybody who tells
you that's not a disturbing videotape
hasn't seen the videotape - as you learn
when you don't need investigations the
videotape tends to tell the end of the
event doesn't always to fix at the
beginning the beginning of the event so
you know that officer is now on modified
assignment that means he was operating
without a badge but I'll be gone on desk
duty pending the investigation we'll
look into every aspect of this what are
the witnesses say are there other videos
what does the officers say who his
partners say you know preliminary
whether it says is that the individual
he has contact with was interfering with
the arrest and then took a fighting
stance of course you know you take you
take that version you take the version
on the video you take what all the
witnesses say and that's what makes up
an investigation so we're very early in
that process but we have a good history
of investigating those things and taking
action where appropriate we're just at
the very beginning well okay you know
it's being reported he's an 8-year
veteran that he
been sued this officer seven times over
the last six years so a lot of people
have a lot of questions about the case
will be following it but of course I
just want to end with this John thank
you for thanks for the messages from
everybody at CBS when I was in the
hospital thanks for your message thanks
for for sending that video for my
daughter's birthday because you know
when you're a 17 year old you know how I
couldn't have a birthday party but we
got 33 pests buying a video and you were
one of them so I appreciate all that
personal we're glad we're we're glad Chi
had a great birthday we're glad someone
said you have coronavirus hair who shall
remain nameless John tower but we're
just glad that you were safe and back on
the job thank you